I wanted to talk a little bit about
um well do you want to talk about
coziness or queerness or both
oh look okay let's talk about Cozy
queerness
um so I think I think queerness is super
cozy there it does all right so it's
made take it away then tell us about
Cozy queerness and and um yeah okay
um so I'm okay coziness right yeah I
think that
um we could all do with being cozy I
think that we and I think that that is
it should not be a controversial thing
to say I think we should I think it
needs to be I think rest needs to be
normalized I think being comfy needs to
be normalized I think uh just indulging
in the beautiful sensory world around
you
is something nobody should feel guilty
about ever
um and I think it's especially important
in the here and now uh when we are all
exhausted and angry and not sure what's
gonna happen not sure if it's ever going
to get any better just you know being
having little pieces of yourself carved
away at every turn to be able to pick up
be it a book a video game a movie
whatever that feels like a great big hug
and we are taught that this is something
childish
um that
you're supposed to grow out of that and
that goes back to what we were talking
about about cynicism and sophistication
um with Monk and robot in particular I I
wrote it
[Music]
um
in response to something I noticed that
was starting to happen in my social
circles around 2017.
you all might have been there at that
point uh
living in this golden age of books media
all of it that you can reach for
anything people started to go back to
and I'm sure a lot of you did this as
well uh Comfort shows from childhood or
watching cartoons
um and both of those things are great
those are legit things to do
um but nobody actually wanted to engage
with new stuff gritty stuff because we
were all so tired all the time and I was
like can I write something that fills
the Steven Universe rewatch or Great
British Bake Off free watch
that is intended for an adult audience
that will give you something nutritious
as well that you're you you can find a
book that meets you where you're at
right now at the age you're at
um
without you know without having to be
like well is it going to end bad I
should read the wiki first I'm sure but
I'm emotionally up for this this evening
um it goes back to comfort it goes back
to a cup of tea
um you just sometimes need a story that
tells you not necessarily that
everything's gonna be okay
but the things are okay that you are
okay
um and I think that that is in in and of
itself a type of rest yeah um I think
yeah I mean there's been um for those of
you who are science fiction fans or pay
attention there has been a whole I would
call it a coziness revolution
um in sci-fi and it's kind of it is very
much a resistance to dystopian writing
um and uh Becky's work is often hailed
as one of the great uh you know aspects
of this coziness revolution
um malka older has a new book out called
the mimicking of known successes which
is also a very cozy uh Space Opera it's
a kind of Sherlock Holmes mystery um Set
uh in an artificial environment that's
been built around Jupiter people have
set up these uh rings around Jupiter
that have trains running on them and
build little habitats around the train
tracks
um and it's just this it's a very like
dark things happen but things are also
quite warm and cozy and like the
characters like each other and they want
to make things better
um and the idea of cozy fiction is not
to avoid Darkness or to you know run
away from problems it really is what
what you're talking about the idea that
you know you're not going to have to
brace yourself for some horrific
destructive uh event at the end of the
day and I think you know um a lot of
Star Trek like not classic Star Trek but
like next Generation era Star Trek kind
of participates in that same narrative
structure where everyone basically wants
to do something that's honorable and
people are there for each other and at
the end of every episode like people fix
things you know like it's not it's not
like Picard if you're watching Picard
where everything is sort of broken and
more broken I haven't watched this
season I hear it's getting better but
um it's much more in the vein of you
know a show where it's we're we're all
there for each other
uh cozy sci-fi can be very simply summed
up as stories that tell you that the
future could be good
yeah that's it that's all it is and if
you choose to pick up a story like that
you're choosing to engage with that idea
for a while for a little while you you
are believing that the future could be
good and that the people in it will be
kind and I think that that's
um that is the fuel we need if we're
going to get through the Here and Now